from the darkness of the calais coast a
french special police team prepares to
break cover
they've been tracking men they believe
to be migrants and asylum seekers
planning to cross the channel
the group take off
the police pursuit is not about
arresting the men but halting the next
stage of their journey intercepting the
small boats they would have made the
crossing in
it was just about without motor only uh
commodity
this boat was almost certainly provided
by smugglers who will have been paid
thousands by those determined to make it
to uk shores
the following morning in sky news is on
board a plane scouring the calais coast
for signs of potential cross-channel
journeys
the pilot spots what he thinks a
migrants or asylum seekers on the beach
police are also alerted to a parked
vehicle with a boat attached and a
search begins for potential smugglers
they and the boats are the target of
this joint french uk operation stop them
the pilot says and people won't be put
in danger
[Music]
those who attempt the journey have
usually taken huge risks just to get to
french shores many escaping war others
poverty but the uk government is
determined to stem what it calls the
illegal trafficking people across the
channel and has handed millions in
recent months to the french to fund
operations on land in the air and at sea
we travel out with the maritime police
who regularly spot boats dangerously
overloaded with people they tell us the
smuggler's tactic is to try to send
multiple vessels out at once making it
difficult for officers to keep track on
them all and at sea there are limits on
what the police can actually do
many on the uk side have accused the
french of not doing enough to stop
migrants and asylum seekers crossing the
channel but once people are actually in
boats and out at sea the objective of
the police is simply to preserve life
even if that means trailing some would
say escorting boats towards uk waters
the french insist they have no legal
right to turn boats back they can only
offer help if needed a position which
has infuriated ministers in britain and
led many to question why the uk
government is funding these operations
at all
[Music]
despite the round-the-clock work on the
french side to thought the smugglers
record numbers of people have made it
across the channel in small boats so far
this year the threat from the uk side of
harsher penalties for those who enter
illegally seemingly little deterrent
michelle clifford sky news calais